تشتهر الحساب معالمها التراثيه العريقه
والتي ستكون مفتوحه امام جماهير كاس
العالم في قطر بحكم قربها الجغرافي ابرز
هذه المعالم المدرسه الاميريه كونها تمثل
رمز التعليم الاول في المنطقه الشرقيه
شيدت عام
1937 المدرسه الاميريه هي اقدم مدرسه
حكوميه في السعوديه وجاء تسميتها نسبه
للعديد من الامراء الذين كانوا من ضمن
طلابها نذاكر والذين لا زالت صورهم
واسمائهم موجوده على جدران المدرسه اسماء
عده من خريجي المدرسه الاميريه من بينهم
خالد الفيصل الامير منطقه مكه المكرمه
ووزير البترول السابق علي العامري ووزير
العمل السابق والاديب الشهير غازي السيد
[موسيقى]
هي احدى محطات توقف القوافل التجاريه
تاريخيه وبوابه دخول القادمين الى
السعوديه وشبه الجزيره العربيه محافظه
الاحساء الضاربه في عرض التاريخ اثرها
الكثيره شاهده دوما على عظمتها ففيها كانت
اوائل المستوطنات البشريه منذ العصر
الحجري ما جعلها بقعه تاريخيه مهمه في
تاريخ المملكه وفي قلب الاحساء يقف قصر
ابراهيم كاحد التحف المعماريه في المملكه
حيث يجمع تصميمه بين العرب والعسكري لكونه
احد اهم قواعد المنطقه وحميتها الاولى
الذي يعد اوائل المساجد التي بنيت في
المنطقه الشرقيه عائدا الى السنه السابعه
للهجره والى جانب الاثار التاريخيه تبدو
الاحساء كواحه مليئه بعيون مياه الطبيعيه
وهي اكثر من 100 عام من المياه اهمها
وانسى دعوه الخدود
[موسيقى]
ومن الاحساء ينضم الينا مراسل صباح
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن
يسعد صباحك اهلا بك المدرسه الاميريه
ايقونه التعليم والشاهد على الانطلاقه
الاولى لمسيره تاريخ التعليم في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
متشوقون لهذه الجوله معك تفضل
اهلا سهام بس بدات سهام انت كيف كنت شاطره
في المدرسه ولا كنتي مجتهده الاولى في
المدرسه يا عبد الرحمن
ههه
يعني جمال البدايات في الابتدائي كنت
ممتاز في الاعدادي والثانوي انا يعني
بعدين بالجامعه استعدت عافيتي بعض الشيء
لكن هذه المدرسه سهام يعني انا رجعتني
ودخلتني حاله مستليج عجيبه همم الفصول
والصفحات والايام خاصه ايام البرد والشتاء
يعني كنا شوي نكره المدرسه اكثر فاكثر لكن
همم هذه المدرسه العريقه جدا والتي همم
اخرجت العديد من الاسماء والشخصيات
السياسيه
ياخذ لكم بعض التفاصيل وناخذ هذه الجوله
طبعا هذه المدرسه سهام كما نشاهد تصميمها
هو مستوحها من تاريخ المنطقه ابواب خشبيه
حتى السقف كمان نشاهد هذه الاخشاب
الموجوده في السقف هي اخشاب منذ تاسيس هذه
المدرسه لم تماس ولم تغير عمره تقريبا
مين ااا سنه ايضا نشاهد هذه قاعه تدريبيه
همم
المدرسه طبعا تم الاستفاده من المدرسه
وتحويلها الى مزار سياحي وايضا الاستفاده
من مرافقها بالنسبه لسكان الاحساء واهالي
المحافظه هذه المدرسه الان تحت اشراف هيئه
التراث التابعه لوزاره الثقافه الان
يقومون بعمليات ترميم وتجهيز لاستقبال
الاف من مشجعين كاس العالم الذين سيقدمون
من قطر التي تبعد تقريبا 200 كيلو همم من
الحساء الان هننزل للدور الثاني ان شاء
الله بس المصور همم
المدرسه
طلاب دفعتها الاولى كانوا 70 طالب فقط حسب
ما عم نشوف الصور المدرسه واسعه وكبيره
صحيح
بالضبط لانه سهام تخيلي اول مدير مدرسه
للمدرسه الاميريه في الحسا ارسل خطاب
ورساله لكل اهالي الاحساء خطاب باليد انه
يا اهل الاحساء دعوا اولادكم يتعلمون
التعليم مهم التدريس مهم ااه كان هناك
صعوبه في استقطاب الطلاب كما نشاهد الان
هذه الصوره هي الصوره لاحد الفصول عام
1947 مشاهده الطلاب عندهم قليل سهام يمكن
تقريبا حوالي 12 طالب ايضا هنا صوره اخرى
لاحد المعلمين وهو يشرح على السبوره
للطلاب فكانت البدايات البدايات التعليم
في السعوديه كانت قليله وعلى استحياء
الاساسيه في الاحساء لكن الان تخيل يا
سهام السعوديه السنويا تخرج 100,000 طالب
من ارقى جامعات العالم من المبتعثين الى
جانب طبعا في كل قريه وفي كل هجره وفي كل
بلده يوجد اكثر من المدرسه على كافه
المراحل التعليميه طبعا الان نحن في الدور
الارضي للمدرسه وهذا العام الرئيس المدرسه
ايضا الباب سهام لم يمس هو من الخشب
القديم عمره في وقت تقريبا 90 سنه تفضل
المدرسه تتميز كمان نلاحظ بتصميم ترافي
فريده تحولت لمزار سياحي هل هي مزار سياحي
فقط اليوم
هي مزار سياحي هي مكان للاستفاده من
المرافق الموجوده فيها هي ايضا معلم مهم
للاحساء طبعا هي في قلب الهفوف القديمه
بالقرب من هنا السوق اللي خرجنا منه قبل
يومين القيصريه ايضا اغلب مواقع تراثيه
قريبه من هنا لان الحساء قديما الهفوف
تحديدا اللي هي قلب الاحساء هذه هي كانت
تقريبا يمكن ثلاثه كيلو في ثلاثه كيلو فقط
همم ولكن الجميل انه هيئه التراث مهتمه
جدا بهذه المواقع والان في عمليات ترميم
وتجهيز والاستقبال المشجعين همم مشجعين
كاس العالم ان شاء الله خلال خمس اربعه
ايام ستكون كل المواقع جاهزه هي الان
مفتوحه تستقبل الزوار لكن ستكون جاهزه
اكثر فاكثر ويتم ايضا همم اعطاء بعض
الاضافات المهمه من المعلومات والصور
والارشادات لاستقبال السياح عبد الرحمن
مبهر دائما لتغطياتك الميدانيه شكرا جزيلا
عبد الرحمن من الاحسان